what's up
hey what is up guys mkbhd here remember
when i said i was moving
this is one of the last videos that you
guys will see
in this apartment i mean i didn't really
literally say like i'm moving out now
but that's kind of what i thought i was
doing so long story short was during
that time i was looking for a place i
found a place i bought a place or at
least i thought i did
and then that fell through because of
the way banks handle the person that's
self-employed didn't really work out
so i was really let down by the fact
that i thought i was about to have a new
space to shoot videos in and then i
suddenly didn't so after that didn't
work out i just started the process over
of looking for a place again and while i
was doing that i also started shooting
my videos outside of my normal spot so
in around town or in spaces in the city
started renting out like studio space
stuff like that just because i was
getting so bored of shooting all my
videos in my one apartment between those
four walls i've read a bit about like
your comfort zone recently and trying to
branch out and stepping outside of your
own comfort zone i like how my hand goes
off the frame when i say that but if
anything is my comfort zone it's
shooting videos in my apartment i've
shot videos in there for like the past
five years you've seen like every
possible angle of that apartment as you
possibly can so it would be really nice
if i could finally get another space to
shoot in but as you can see between all
those videos searching for things
visiting them pouring over the details
finally found something and it's looking
pretty dope so this is the studio as you
can see i'm really glad i found it uh i
just it was it's super empty right now
as you can see and here uh there's a lot
of unfilled space but right off frame
over there there's a bunch of stuff that
you can't even see bringing in stuff for
the first time to set it up i've talked
about this stuff and showed a little bit
of it on my twitter and especially
snapchat mostly behind the scenes of
setting up the studio has been going on
snapchat because that's just easy now
you can definitely hear that there's a
good echo
in here like a good solid one and a half
two second echo from what i'm talking
that's going to be my number one
challenge with this spot is not making
it video ready because it definitely
already is but making it audio ready and
making it totally
normal sounding to make videos here now
there's already a little bit of foam in
the ceiling going up the echo used to be
like i would snap and you wouldn't stop
hearing it for a solid six seconds so
where i'm at right now is a little bit
of an improvement thanks to the foam but
when i get like you know couch and desks
and more carpeting and things in here a
lot of that stuff is going to dampen the
sound and one by one when i get
furniture in that's going to make a big
difference but as of right now my number
one challenge is making this place more
audio ready and not like an echo chamber
anyway i don't want to bore you with all
the brutal details of it but essentially
i figured i would show you guys a little
bit more as i start to move into this
place over the next couple of days and
weeks and months a little bit beyond
what i was just showing on twitter and
snapchat now i can already answer some
of the most common questions i've seen
from the comments on twitter and
instagram and people talking about it is
uh number one am i living here
no i'm not this is actually a dedicated
video space and it's actually for the
first time in my life going to be
separate in a separate room from where i
live and sleep which believe it or not
is a bit of a challenge the number two
thing i've probably seen is
why do you need all this space to make
videos again it comes down to the
comfort zone thing i'm trying to get out
of my comfort zone trying to branch out
more and also trying to make a little
bit more and a little bit different
stuff which i've talked a lot about but
again have been in the same apartment
not really doing it so here we are i can
actually host things now i can bring
people in if people want to work
alongside me for one project or for a
long term that can happen wink wink if
you're a youtuber in the new york city
area you're invited come on over have a
party so collabs can happen here videos
can happen here it's sort of a place to
bring people and things in that's not
awkward in my apartment the way it is
now so i'm really excited for the
possibilities there and that's pretty
much it i mean my goal at the end of the
day is to make better videos and
hopefully it's a win-win hopefully this
space is a win for me because i'm
stepping out of my apartment and out of
my comfort zone and making new better
stuff and a win for you you because it's
a better space it's going to look better
it's going to eventually sound better
and it's going to allow a little bit
more of a variety of the type of stuff
that comes out of this channel
and that's pretty much it also my daily
driver right now for those who are
wondering is a galaxy s7 edge it's a
titanium silver one although that might
change in the next couple days just
because of the amount of phones that are
coming out right now so anyway that's
the situation for those who are asking
and yeah that's pretty much it i'm gonna
get to moving and bringing more stuff in
thanks for watching
i'll talk to you guys the next one
peace
you